[Musique]
est ce que vous savez comment on
reconnaît un pilote de chasse dans une
soirée non bah vous en faites pas il va
venir vous le dire
et d'ailleurs je suis venu vous le dire
quand j'étais plus jeune j'étais pilote
de chasse dans l'aéronavale et pour vous
décrire un peu le pilote que j'étais je
vous dirais un ego démesuré un orgueil
surdimensionné et un profond sentiment
d'invulnérabilité sans oublier le
blouson de cuir et les lunettes de
soleil un pilote c'est un gestionnaire
de situation complexe
20 pilotes s'entraînent à gérer
l'imprévu et à faire face à des
événements stressants et ne croyez pas
qu'il y ait plus d'événements stressant
dans un cockpit d'avion que dans la vie
de tous les jours
la différence c'est que dans l'avion le
pilote ils sont en train de faire face
tous les jours surtout quand ça va bien
la vie elle peut être remplie
d'événements stressant auquel chacun
fait face différemment parce qu'on a
chacun notre propre échelle du malheur
ceci dit il existe une sorte de
consensus
une étude qui propose une échelle des
stresseurs cette échelle est très
largement utilisé entre autres dans les
eaux nautique et elles classent les
événements de la vie en fonction de
l'impact qu'ils ont sur un individu de 0
à 100 est en haut de cette échelle à 100
on trouve l'événement qui a le plus
d'impact
le décès du conjoint le décès de
l'enfant n'est pas évalué dans cette
étude
bien qu'il s'agisse d'un traiteur d'un
stresseurs d'une intensité extrême alors
sur notre échalas sens on a le décès du
conjoint
puis vers 75 on a le divorce et la
séparation puis vers 55
on a sa propre maladie et son
licenciement bien évidemment il n'a
d'autre des événements et en plus on
peut les cumuler et puis un jour un de
ces événements il fait basculer la vie
et ma vie a basculé
un soir de décembre
ce jour là cette époque là ça faisait
cinq ans que ma femme était en
chimiothérapie de manière ininterrompue
et depuis plusieurs jours elle avait des
douleurs insoutenables
j'appelle le médecin je dis ça va plus
il me répond je savais que ça arriverait
on pas ce qu'il veut me dire
peut-être je veux pas comprendre ce
qu'il veut me dire le médecin prescrit
des médicaments que je donne à ma femme
et ils lui permettent enfin de
s'endormir de se reposer sans souffrir
et ce soir là ça fait quarante huit
heures qu'elle s'est endormie
est ce que je sais pas c'est qu'elle se
réveillera pas on est allongé tous les
deux dans notre lit comme tous les soirs
puis sa respiration devient bruyante je
lui parle de prendre mes bras je la
serre contre moi puis sa respiration se
transforme en inspiration ses
inspirations deviennent de petites
aspirations l'air finit par ne plus
rentrer et puis quelques petits
soubresauts de ses lèvres et plus rien
je sais pas moins que je suis en train
de vivre sa mort tout s'est arrêté dans
mes bras dans mes mains quand j'ai
compris le chagrin et monter en moi
comme comme la foudre de l'orage comme
une vague qui m'a submergé comment faire
face à des événements stressants à des
situations dramatiques et irréversible
il est impossible d'anticiper la
violence du choc
par contre on peut se préparer pour
gérer la suite
on peut préparer sa résilience pour
avancer sur le magnifique chemin de la
reconstruction
alors pour vous parler de résilience
permettez moi de vous présenter une
population je connais bien et pilote les
pilotes sont résilients il s'entraîne à
être résiliente
vous avez peut-être prendre l'avion
différemment si je vous dis qu avant
chaque décollage un pilote répète sa
procédure de pannes au décollage sur
voix qui me regardait les grands yeux un
pilote et ni superstitieux ni pessimiste
et ne pense pas qu'il va tomber en panne
mais se préparent ils pas question de
prévoir l'avenir parce que personne ne
peut prédire l'avenir même un pilote de
chasse en aéronautique
selon les statistiques un seul accidents
par million de décollage pourtant le
pilote il répète inlassablement tous les
jours sa procédure pour se préparer à
faire face à une panne il met en place
des piliers sur lesquels il va pouvoir
s'appuyer pour faire face aux événements
il peut alors se concentrer pleinement
sur son vol et vivre des émotions
positives dans des situations
potentiellement stressante
il envisage alors sereinement la
possibilité d'une panne
l'objectif c'est pas de minimiser
l'effet de surprise mais c'est de
renforcer ses capacités pour gérer la
suite c'est le premier pas vers la
résilience bon
je vous parle de pilote et je parle
d'avions mais c'est pareil dans la vie
de tous les jours construire sa
résilience c'est une démarche
quotidienne
ça se prépare déjà quand tout va bien
c'est tout ce que l'on met en place
maintenant qui va nous permettre de
gérer de construire nos piliers de vie
pour l'avenir mais plia moi c'est la
famille l'amour
mes amis mon métier mes passions ses
piliers
il structure ma vie et ils ont toujours
guidé ma construction du bonheur j'avais
jamais imaginé qu'un jour il serait la
base de ma résilience quand j'ai perdu
ma femme c'est mon pilier de l'amour qui
s'est effondré et j'avais ma famille
avec qui j'ai changé mes amis avec qui
je partageais mon métier qui m'épanouit
quand un pilier s'effondre on peut
essayer d'en reconstruire un nouveau ou
alors on peut réaménager les autres
différemment autour des ruines de celui
qui s'est effondré vivre avec le
souvenir
il arrive que l'on cumule les événements
de la vie est là ce sont plusieurs
piliers qui peuvent s'effondrer en même
temps la reconstruction peut être plus
complexe
un pilier qui s'effondre c'est la
structure de l'édifice
il remise en cause on a chacun un ou
plusieurs piliers plus solide que les
autres y en a pour qui c'est la famille
pour d'autres les amis la musique le
sport ou même l'argent chacun son truc
les enfants les enfants c'est un pilier
majeur dans la vie des parents les
enfants qui grandissent puis un jour et
quitte la maison et quittent le nid bon
y'a des fois on est un peu impatient qui
prennent leur envol
mais quand ils partent c'est un pilier
qui disparaît ça peut être un vrai
bouleversement pour certains métiers
égale passion un seul pilier n'est comme
métier s'arrête c'est pas un pays qui
s'effondre ces deux méfiance structure
et aménager ses piliers les entretenir
c'est se préparer à faire face aux
événements de la vie c'est un peu une
une assurance bien sûr construire ses
piliers c'est comme ça c'est la vie
c'est d'abord une démarche individuelle
mais c'est aussi une démarche avec les
autres il ya une étude qui a été
réalisée dans les cockpits d'avion et
qui montre que certains équipages arrive
à gérer l'imprévu de manière optimale
alors que d'autres n'y arrive pas ou
moins bien et ce qui fait la différence
c'est bien sûr la préparation mais c'est
surtout la communication entre les
membres d'équipage
cette connexion qu'ils auront établi et
qui va leur permettre d'avancer ensemble
s'impliquer ensemble pour construire ses
propres piliers et aider l'autre à
construire les siens des publications
récentes en psychologie montrent que
lorsqu'on est de l'autre on crée un
bonheur qui profite à trois personnes à
celle qui est aidée à celle qui aide
l'autre et en plus à celles qui
regardent ceux qui s'aident
souvenez-vous pendant le confinement
on a vu toutes ces initiatives de
solidarité
ça vous a pas fait chaud au coeur
cette connexion aux autres elle nous
permet de construire notre propre
résilience et celle de ceux qui nous
entourent
grâce à une écoute un geste un regard
grâce à nos mains à notre coeur
grâce à un je t'aime quelle richesse là
chaque nouvelle journée
c'est un nouveau départ un nouveau
décollage et pour se préparer à faire
face aux événements pour vivre des
émotions positives
il n'est pas forcément utile de vouloir
tout changer ou tout anticiper pour
piloter sa résilience soyons simplement
attentif à la structure de notre
quotidien à ce que l'on vit maintenant à
nos piliers de vie des piliers que l'on
peut construire pour soi même avec les
autres et pour les autres bon alors et
vous c'est quoi bon pilier de vie
merci
[Applaudissements]